ADAM SCHIFF.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
>> THOSE OF YOU AT HOME, TIME TO
CHANGE THE CHANNEL, TURN DOWN
THE VOLUME.
OR HIDE THE KIDS COME UP WITH
THEM TO BED.
I YIELD TO MR. SCHIFF FOR
STORY TIME HOUR.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU THINK BACK
ON YOUR DAYS IN KINDERGARTEN OR
FIRST GRADE MAY BE, YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER THAT TIME EACH WEEK
WHEN YOUR TEACHER OR MAYBE A
SPECIAL GUEST SAT ON A STOOL OR
ON THE FLOOR WITH THE CHILDREN
GATHERING AROUND, AND FABLED
FAIRY TALES OR OTHER STORIES
WERE READ ALOUD TO US WIDE-EYED
CHILDREN WHO TOOK IT ALL IN.
TROLLS, WIZARDS, THERE WERE
TALKING PIGS.
IT WAS ALL MAGICAL.
THE WORDS AND THE DELIVERY MADE
THE FICTIONAL CHARACTERS COME TO
LIFE.
BUT THEN WE GREW UP, OR AT LEAST
SOME OF US DID.
OTHERS ARE STILL SELLING FICTION
AND ACTING LIKE IT IS REAL LIFE.
>> THE TESTIMONY TODAY IS AMONG
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE TO
DATE.
AND WHAT WE HAVE JUST HEARD FROM
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND IS THAT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS, THIS
CONDITIONING OF THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS A BASIC QUID PRO QUO.
IT GOES RIGHT TO THE HEART OF
THE ISSUE OF BRIBERY AS WELL AS
OTHER POTENTIAL HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
>> Laura: ALL DAY, SCHIFF
TRIED TO PLAY THE ROLE OF SIR
LANCELOT, WHO RUSHES IN TO SLAY
THE TRUMP DRAGON.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA PLAYING THE
PART OF OBJECTIVE JOURNALISTS
TRIED TO HELP HIM.
>> THIS IS A BOMBSHELL BUT IT IS
EXPLOSIVE.
VERY EXPLOSIVE.
>> THIS IS A SLOW-MOTION
EXPLOSION.
>> I CAN'T EMPHASIZE HOW
EXPLOSIVE THIS IS.
>> WE HAVE WITNESSED TODAY ON
LIVE TELEVISION, RIVETING.
>> AMBASSADOR SONDLAND TESTIMONY
HAD SUCH GRAVITY TO IT.
SPEAK OF THIS WAS AN IED FROM
MR. SOLID.
HE EXPLODED.
>> Laura: HE PHYSICALLY
EXPLODED?
THAT COULD HAVE GOTTEN MESSY.
BUT WHEN WE LEAVE THEIR WORLD OF
MAKE-BELIEVE, WE SEE THAT THERE
IS NO THERE THERE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP NEVER TOLD ME
DIRECTLY THAT THE AIDE WAS
CONDITIONED ON THE MEANS.
>> SO IT WASN'T REALLY A
PRESUMPTION, YOU HEARD FROM
MR. GIULIANI?
>> I DIDN'T HEAR FROM
MR. GIULIANI ABOUT THE EIGHT, I
HEARD ABOUT BURISMA AND 2016.
>> YOU UNDERSTOOD AT THAT POINT
AS WE DISCUSSED, TWO PLUS TWO
EQUALS FOUR, THE AIDE WAS THERE
AS WELL APPEARED >> THAT WAS THE
PROBLEM, NO ONE TOLD ME DIRECTLY
THAT THE AIDE
WAS TIED TO ANYTHING.
I WAS PRESUMING IT WAS.
>> Laura: PRESUMING, THINKING,
BELIEVING, FEELING.
WE ARE GOING TO IMPEACH A
PRESIDENT ON SOMEONE'S OPINION
IN THE ABSENCE OF COLD, HARD
FACT?
THERE WERE A LOT OF OPINIONS AND
BELIEFS OF TODAY BUT ZERO
EVIDENCE.
>> MY BELIEF WAS, I BELIEVE THAT
WAS TO BE THE CASE.
I WAS PRESUMING THAT IT WAS.
>> I THINK.
>> MY PERSONAL PRESUMPTION.
>> THAT WAS MY BELIEF.
>> MY PERSONAL BELIEF.
>> MY PERSONAL BELIEF, AS YOU
PUT IT, TWO PLUS TWO EQUALS
FOUR.
>> Laura: HE'S GOOD AT MATH,
TOO.
TWO PLUS TWO EQUALS FOUR?
THAT RIGHT.
RIVETING, EXPLOSIVE!
AND HOW PERSUASIVE.
CONGRESSMAN BRAD WENSTRUP,
ALTHOUGH NOT A LAWYER, HAD FUN
WITH THAT.
>> A MATHEMATIC FACT, TWO PLUS
TWO DOZEN FACT EQUAL FOUR.
BUT IN REALITY, TWO PRESUMPTIONS
PLUS TWO PRESUMPTIONS DOES NOT
EQUAL EVEN ONE FACT.
>> Laura: I'VE BEEN TELLING
YOU FOR MANY WEEKS THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE IMPEACHMENT BY
OPINION OR SUPPOSITION OR
HEARSAY WITH NO UNDERLYING
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
NOTHING EVEN CLOSE TO AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
NOTHING THAT WAS SAID TODAY
CHANGED THAT.
CONGRESSMAN MIKE TURNER BROUGHT
EVERYONE DOWN TO EARTH.
>> AFTER YOU TESTIFY, CHAIRMAN
SCHIFF RAN OUT AND GAVE A PRESS
CONFERENCE SAYING HE GETS TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE OF YOUR
TESTIMONY AND IF YOU PULL UP CNN
TODAY, RIGHT NOW THERE BANNER
SAYS "A SONDLAND TIES TRUMP TO
WITHHOLDING AID."
IS THAT YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY?
I SAID REPEATEDLY.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I WAS PRESUMING.
>> NO ONE ON THIS PLANET TOLD
YOU THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS TYING
THIS AID TO THE INVESTIGATION,
BECAUSE IF YOUR ANSWER IS YES,
THEN THE CHAIRMAN IS WRONG IN
THE HEADLINE ON CNN IS WRONG.
NO ONE ON THIS PLANET TOLD YOU
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS TYING
ADD
AID TO INVESTIGATION.
>> YES.
>> SO YOU REALLY HAVE NO
TESTIMONY TODAY THAT TIES
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO A SCHEME TO
WITHHOLD AID FROM UKRAINE IN
EXCHANGE FOR THESE
INVESTIGATIONS.
>> OTHER THAN MY OWN
PRESUMPTION.
>> WHICH IS NOTHING.
>> Laura: THIS WAS
UNBELIEVABLE.
HE IS THINKING, HOW SOON CAN I
GET ON THAT PLANE BACK TO
BRUSSELS?
SPEAKING OF PRESUMPTIONS, AS
AMERICANS, WE PRESUME, DON'T WE,
THAT CONGRESS WILL ACTUALLY WORK
IN THE NATION'S INTEREST.
THAT IT WILL PURSUE SOUND
LEGISLATION AND OVERSIGHT FOR
SURE WITH DEEP RESPECT FOR THE
CONSTITUTION.
YET IN WATCHING THIS TRAVESTY
PLAY OUT, WE SEE JUST HOW NAIVE
THAT PRESUMPTION IS.
AND ONE FINAL THOUGHT, RECALL
HOW OFTEN DEMOCRATS HAVE TROTTED
OUT THIS LINE.
>> DO YOU AGREE THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO ASK THE
INVESTIGATION OF A POLITICAL
RIVAL?
>> YOU SAID IT'S WRONG TO
INVESTIGATE POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
YOU DO THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
AND OBJECTIONABLE TO SEEK TO GET
A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
INVESTIGATE A POLITICAL RIVAL,
AM I RIGHT?
>> Laura: SHOULD CALL THEM
HYPOCRITICAL IS A GROSS
UNDERSTATEMENT TONIGHT.
INVESTIGATING THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENT IS PRECISELY WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN DOING TO
TRUMP SINCE 2016.
AND TO DO SO, THEY HAVE USED THE
PFIZER COURSE, THEY USED
INFORMANTS, THEY TROTTED OUT
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, THEY TRIED
TO TAKE DOWN HIS FAMILY, THEY
EMPLOYED MOLD AND USE IT USE
FOREIGN INTERMEDIARIES, THAT'S
ALL.
UKRAINE AID WAS DELAYED FOR
WHAT, A FEW WEEKS?
HE GOT HIS MEETING WITHOUT
HAVING TO ENHANCE ANY
INVESTIGATION AND ZELENSKY SAID
HIS CONVERSATION WITH TRUMP ON
JULY 25TH WAS NORMAL.
NO PRESSURE.
AMERICANS ARE SAVVY AND THEY ARE
SMART.
AND I BET MOST DEEP DOWN IN THE
SENSE THAT THIS HAS BEEN AND
CONTINUES TO BE A COLOSSAL WASTE
OF TIME.
GREAT ECONOMIC NEWS KEEPS
ROLLING IN, MEANWHILE.
FOLKS ARE ALREADY LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE HOLIDAYS.
I AM.
TRUMP'S POLICIES MEAN THAT MORE
PEOPLE WILL GET BONUSES THIS
CHRISTMAS.
IF YOU ARE ARE OUT OF WORK.
THAT IS ALL GREAT NEWS.
EVEN IF IN SILENCE DEMOCRATS ARE
SUFFERING FROM A WICKED CASE OF
BUYERS REMORSE TONIGHT, A NEW
POLL THE IMPORTANT BATTLEGROUND
STATE OF WISCONSIN IT SHOWS
TRUMP BEATING EVERY TOP
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE.
GALLUP HAS ITS APPROVAL NUMBERS
UP TWO-POINT EVEN AS SCHIFF'S
GRIMM FAIRY TALE.
STORY TIME IS ALMOST OVER, BUT